there's another impossible level little
critters those already up over here we
go we're gonna make it we're gonna make
it we're going on a poon run everybody
loves a good poon run boop bop fly
through the air for you jet fall with
Santa's log little is just tumbling in
the wall over under method just tuck my
legs between my head watch tuck my head
between my legs and tumble to my doom
I know yet pack your ID press space to
start hold spaces Auto Alban art nerds
Oh pink cute oh my god
spacebar use arrow keys no yeah yeah
you can walk and shoot look everybody I
walk in I see oh my god I think I think
I think I won a laid writer you'll need
your arms to finish okay what are we
doing here
what do we do oh what Oh what
funny sward throw funny you think you
are
um I'm a professional I can't get the
sword why can i oh there we go let's see
it is now your opportunity to avenge
them extremely strong oh yeah suck on
that bed oh my god alright yeah alright
cut is don't get ahead of yourself
we just need a good over the thing
okay okay let's stir this again more
better oh my god
balance it's too high for even my
proneness pepper got it now that shoot
me
oh not there neon Pogo Adventure well
here we go oh I thought that was gonna
be one oh man oh man everyone knows I
hate you freaking oh my god okay people
are trying to murder us was not
expecting that bro no miss me suck on
that [ __ ] juice you little [ __ ] oh god
my chin my rock-hard chin try one more
time
[Music]
yes
yeah oh I think there is just oblivion
over here son
bye-bye her pain run for life is this
like Relay for Life Wow okay trying this
again just gentle it's like that
helicopter game nerds nerds nerds want
some yards without my head is it still
possible to kill myself I think yes
maybe out not did not kill myself but I
guess we're doing okay alright good for
us we do okay if only we had potatoes
good alright you can either the name of
the truffle is the will you live
obviously you will not but you will make
her that sad I died like a donut damn it
thank you what I mean Kelly who you see
it's a bar on a bar run everybody loves
a ball run all got it's wrong it's
different it's different it's different
why is it different why are you
different
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna be king of the bottle run right
here best ever oh you bastards okay one
more time Blade Runner yep these stupid
Cylons or whatever the [ __ ] they're
called want to kill me I mean whatever
the [ __ ] they're called cuz I don't
curse in this have a happy wheels is
happy fun show only for kids only that's
right
with off the nards and balls in stabbing
and fastness
impale him I shall oh hang on wait I
need to impale you thank you thank you
very much I'll take your legs
have fun in death land No you surprised
me lady hard Pogo of death why no no no
oh you didn't get me that I didn't even
get killed on the spikes why gimme
I'll just testing you just testing your
spike miss which I find lacking human
throw all right then ah no I missed Oh
My these humans are too hard to throw
let me just get the winner's circle
yeah what's wrong with you people huh
but it's gone an adventure sir
whatever your name is I'm guessing it's
Zack Scott but I'm not sure it's just to
kill them all can I go crazy
[Music]
let's go son go
hoodies I'm a little confused by this
one
this one is called spear wave surfing
why do guys oh wait where we going can I
stalk don't go
goodbye forever Cuddy I was really well
done there no appreciate the cleverness
and the raining blood that is what could
what's going on here where's my credit I
don't know what's going on but let me
just hump this with you to make sense
you didn't see anything in the last one
nothing weird happened so coke and
mentos cuz everyone knows that this
works together hip if I could get a free
eye one eye - let's try one more time I
like this one this is actually pretty
unique oh wow in my ass ass ass ow ow
okay what I have to do is I have to use
these these these landmines to launch
myself or off
that did not go as planned
I'm gonna get this skinny ski Oh Oh
bottle run wait for screen why why do I
need to wait for screen run oh please
we're not gonna come up here
well go got over the thingy I know
you're ready to go head towards it
because you wanna die
all right try this again SuperSpeed on
this one No Oh what I'll take your axe
no I didn't I didn't like your axe
anyway get out of here
suck on that [ __ ] no no no no no oh no
oh no you didn't hope you think you shut
this again more better more better
glowing rope swing we we're glowing
oh we're glowing no my arm I tried to
grab with my bad arm all right kiddies
we need to fly look at the little
butterfly over these obstacles but we do
not die okay good job cut it
Goodwin taking one in the nards for
Santa just like last night
what I have to do is I have to use these
landmines to law hoe go through my neck
through my neck still alive dead take it
again cuz I am - awesome - so close now
all right get east ruin another jet wall
you'll know how they clean normally go
you need to avoid the stupid jack don't
touch don't touch
super powerful run very long super extra
bottle extra bottle awesome run good
follow me I am too amazing four of these
look how good I play I am too a pro and
all pogo jumps here and there's been a
lot of murdering of myself by myself
so let's another time arrows oh you
could just hold on your horses fly fly
fly fly
oh come on you can't burn me that hard
my son
wherever you went oh good good his flies
I go thank you thank you thank you thank
you so much oh let's try this again okay
okay so we need to go faster kiddo pick
up the speed start pedaling there you
lazy bum run
wrong you catch maggot it's a lie
Paula trick trick see trick don't go
just don't go don't go at all it's bad
news no ultimate defense escape death
death inbound do something this has been
happy wheels highlights thanks for
watching if you like what your son you
want to see more why not subscribe to my
channel want to help the channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]